let me move on to
uh video games and
let's do a quick google search for um
what they call them esports esports
i don't know champions i'll call it uh
let's call it uh 2019. let's see who
these guys are
so china's fun plus phoenix defeat e2
sports
league of champions world championship
okay so who are these guys here we go
uh let's put this up on the screen so we
can add to stream
so this is the people that compete
on video games i'm not opposed
i'm not completely opposed to video
games they can be fun
there's certain times where
um i'm not going to say it's a good use
of your time
but there's certain times where you can
engage you can have community you can do
some [ __ ] with your friends you can have
some fun
you can at least challenge yourself to
some degree you know one might even
argue it helps develop hand-eye
coordination but it's very very limited
um my point being with video games is
these are the people that are considered
world class so
uh league of legends world champion so
this is
now this is a big big thing that is
going to open up a lot of doors
um and a lot of traffic for new
businesses going forward
i'm actually looking at an esports
platform to invest in at an early stage
right now
um because i know it's so popular it's
going to continue to be popular
but these are the champions okay these
are the league of legends world
champions
they are world champions at their video
games at that craft
i don't believe that they are
legends of mankind okay if i can put it
that way
i'm you know putting it putting it
kindly if you will
um they're pretty much dorks
where's where's another one here we go
see what these guys look like
okay so playing video games is not
competing in real life is what my point
is
these are the people that you're
competing against can i make this any
bigger for you
there you go these are the dorks that
you're competing against
i bet i would i would bet you these guys
look like they're at least 20 years
younger than me
i would bet you that i could probably do
at least 30
more push-ups than all of these dorks
chin-ups
squats i could probably hop on my bike
and ride way faster way further than any
of these guys
they're not they're not doing anything
that's improving themselves
as men all they're doing is they're
competing on an
online game with wicked hand-eye
coordination
and here's their trophy like this is
what they have to show for it
i don't believe that this is something
that is a good use of your time
and if i'm being honest there's far far
better things
that you guys can be doing with your
time when it comes to
engaging on consoles computers and stuff
like that
use it in a very very limited basis
most of the stuff in video games
especially if you go to places like
twitch
now there's a lot of these e thoughts
coming into these platforms
that men are getting thirsty for and
they're white knighting for
and they're bending the knee for and it
better ties as men
right it makes them weaker they're
okay i'm gonna end on this note on the
video game thing to
set the example in the tone in a clear
concise manner um
but five or six years ago i was skiing
and in the train park i wiped out
and i thought i broke my shin i couldn't
put any weight onto it i went
immediately to the emergency
room of the hospital i'm sitting there
waiting for about
five hours ninety percent of the traffic
in there was
uh single moms bringing in their kids
that had a slight cough or a dot on
their back
and then there was a couple of other
kids that were in there as well the one
that went in before me
sat you know they have these curtain
rooms with it with a drawstring curtain
so you can hear everything
doctors like okay so what's the problem
what can i do to help you why are you
here today he goes
well you know i was sitting around
playing video games this weekend and i
can't feel my legs
and she says some okay well what
happened you know why can't you feel
you don't feel your legs why did they go
numb because he said they went numb and
they couldn't feel them
well i was on this long raid with a
bunch of my friends online on world of
warcraft for like two and a half days
straight
and um yeah i just don't feel them
they're really numb and she's like well
get up and walk around
dummy this is the kind of
man that video games facilitate it
facilitates
the weak beta that sits around on his
ass all day
and doesn't use the rest of his body and
sits in a chair and that's what you end
up becoming you know you become
a chair uh globule is essentially what
you end up doing
you need to compete in real life you
need to win in real life
so if you're going to play games fine do
it but do it on a limited basis get your
ass off the computer screen
off the console and off these devices
and go and compete in real life
pick up a sport join a dojo learn how to
get into some form of combat sports that
you enjoy maybe boxing maybe bjj maybe
krav maga
i don't care do something to compete in
real life
men need strong competency skills
learning combat sports is a far better
use of your time than sitting around
playing mortal kombat
okay you're going to end up like the
dork that was in the hospital
because he couldn't feel his legs
because he sat around for three days
straight
doing nothing be careful with these
inputs these are the things that will
beta ties you
um if you want to read a really
interesting book
on uh companies and
people that are so brilliant that they
know how to form
um habit like these habit-forming
products
uh it's called hooked the book is called
hooked
author's name is near i think it's ny
let me just quickly look it up this is
this is a great book i mean
if you play video games right now and
you're wondering why by
here it is there it is um near
n-i-r-e-y-a-l
read this book over here how to build
habit forming products
he breaks down specifically how things
like
facebook how things like video games
uh and console games and even computer
type of games
get you hooked to keep coming back and
spending all your time and money
staring at the screen or at their
product or service
um it's a really really interesting read
i would highly encourage
you to take a look at it especially if
you feel like you have an addictive
personality
to these types of products and services
because you need to get your head around
why you're doing this and unhook
yourself from
it
you